but let's go back to turkey and our
international affairs editor dominic why
corn was at that news conference in
antalya with sega lavrov dominic so from
what we can take from those two press
conferences where are we with these
talks
yeah well i think uh the headlines are
that they haven't really made any
headway at all um lavrov said that these
are meant to be separate from the bella
russian uh diplomatic track and
therefore russians can't deliver on
things like ceasefires or humanitarian
humanitarian aid corridors dmitry caleb
his counterpart for the ukrainians said
that as far as he's concerned uh lavrov
came here without a mandate that all
those things had to be referred back up
to moscow and clearly khalid was very
frustrated by that i mean whoever's
right there that the bottom line is that
these talks have not delivered on a
ceasefire or humanitarian aid corridors
and therefore you kind of wonder what
the point was apart from both men to
come here and lay out their talking
points again i asked lavrov i asked him
about the credibility of the russians
really you know they said they weren't
going to invade ukraine they have uh and
they said that they're going to not hurt
civilians and thousands of civilians are
being hurt or millions have been
displaced but i think if i'd had a
follow-up question and we weren't given
more than one question i would have
asked him what planet he's on because he
also said in this press conference up
there that russia has not invaded or
attacked ukraine where clearly it has
you know he is a veteran well-respected
russian diplomat but he's sticking to
those talking points that rush is just
involved in a strictly limited military
operation it's not a war it's not an
invasion if you use those words where
diana is you could end up in jail for 15
years and lavrov despite being a
respected diplomat was sticking to that
script even though he sounds absurd he
sounds like he's in a parallel universe
i think
also talking about the hospital that
diana was talking about there he was
sticking to the script there as well
which
straight slightly from what his
spokesman was saying maria zakharova was
saying before the press conference that
she felt that all the pictures of this
maternity hospital were fate
whereas lavrov her boss was saying no
that they felt that this hospital was
being used by a far right the azov
brigade so that's a far right wing of
the ukrainian military in the minds of
the russians and therefore they would
have had a right to attack it and that's
typical russian misinformation putting
out conflicting stories often
self-contradictory but to put up a sort
of smoke screen that confuses people
watching what you have to say as a
dispassionate observer about attacking
hospitals is the world health
organization says that 18 medical
facilities have been hit now in in
ukraine three
over the last 24 hours or so the most
recent one on maternity hospital and
you've got to say that that's a chilling
echo of what russia did in syria where
it was supporting the syrian regime and
the iranians it would deliberately
attack hospitals with a rather cynical
aim of forcing civilians to flee if you
live somewhere and the safest place in
your town is a hospital for most people
it would be and you hear it's been
struck
then you're inclined not to stay put
you're going to flee and what the
russians are facing in ukraine is
a people power problem that the people
coming out on the streets they are
fronting up with the tanks they're lying
down in front of the tanks very brave
ukrainians are uh trying to push the
russian soldiers out of their towns just
through people power so one way of
dealing with that is to just make people
flee and i think you have to suspect
that is the strategy behind what the
russians appear to be doing now which is
using airstrikes to target hospitals
even though we've heard two different
sort of answers about what the hospitals
what the hospital attack was all about
from these two spokesperson for the
russian government i think it's very
worrying
about what the future could be uh
bringing in coming hours and days for
the people of ukraine and their medical
facilities